there was a lot of michael jackson
dancing and really a great impression of
him and then i just found out uh
recently that you guys were pretty good
friends oh yeah man i was blessed man to
you know to grow up and to meet my
somebody i idled and admired so much man
and become his friend i was in one of
his videos and stuff and just love mike
i mean we just we became friends man i
hung out with him a lot and michael was
just so nice man you'd be around him and
you just get happy man he would he would
give you anything if you liked something
like i was just complimenting a flat
screen tv head and he gave it to me i
was like
i didn't want the tv
but then the black came out of me i
started liking everything after that
i said mike i like that rolls royce
that's a bad rolls royce it's not the
one the new rolls royce right there
he was like you like it chris i said
yeah i like it so you sure you like it i
said yeah
he said well you better go buy one
because i ain't giving you
i gave you a tv damn
and michael was so famous he had to
disguise himself and we would come
downstairs i'd be like where's michael
michael be covered up like i'm over here
chris from here
michael that's you yeah
so we going to movies and i'm thinking
you know i'm trying to be secret too you
know i'm hiding myself then michael
laughing louder than anybody everybody
know michael's laughing right
i was like michael shut up what what is
your family's reaction to to to your
success oh they all quit their jobs when
they finally make a 20 million
what's it like in china with jackie chan
is it just ridiculous he's the man
jackie owned everything he's like you
like hotel
you said you like hotels yeah it's my
hotel that's my hotel no cause i got to
do my movie
but he really just goes over and just
like walks around with like 15 people
and then i'm like in the back of the 15
people jackie wait up hold
it's gonna look up man we're supposed to
be together what did you spend money on
i spent oh i spent i was spending too
much money i like i was i didn't know i
was just acting crazy i bought two
houses right next door to each other it
was crazy
i said i'll take that one too i don't
want anybody to mess with me yeah i was
borrowing stuff for myself that was
crazy that's gotta be crazy too
i said you got some sugar i can borrow
you know we got some sugar i'm you and
you me man
uh russia did what like 180 billion
dollars some crazy amount yeah people
don't realize though you don't get all
that money though you got to pay taxes
that's half of it you got to pay a
lawyer because you got to have a lawyer
then i got you you got to take care of
your family a couple of cousins willy
uncle leroy
and you probably need a new you got
relatives you didn't know you met before
they come out oh man i got so many new
relatives it's just so crazy they come
up to me you know i'm your cousin your
grandma know who i am i'm your cousin i
said no you my grandma my cousin
she know you i don't know you like did
you get did you go through a phase where
people treated you like smokey and what
what did they offer you because of
obviously the character you're playing
weeds weed
white kids used to come to my house and
want to smoke weed with me i said i
don't smoke weed man i was a character
get off my porch
you get me locked up get out of here
donald trump your president uh what do
you consider him your president
do you mean donald
are you serious
believe me believe believe me i know
chris tucker he's a great comedian great
guy i like him
i'm it's true i do like him i met him
wait i didn't say much but i said hello
believe me you know princess josh so he
i didn't know i just heard this noise
behind me and i didn't know what it was
he just tried to get my attention he was
like
he was like
he said nice prince trying to get your
attention so i turned around and i said
hey
he's small so i was like hey prince how
you doing
oh man i love jackie but jackie used to
make me look bad he used to show up to
work on time all the time i said jackie
you're the star man take it easy trailer
you're making me look bad man he said
chris you're messing you're wasting
money get on set on time
he said it ain't your money jackie no
seriously want a brother he is like that
he oh yeah he's prom he's a great dude
dude man love him man
when you work with him he he his english
isn't great so you have to hang
jack is fighting on every word right
jackie i'll be having jackie words all
on me on on paper what you call it like
cardboard to be taped on me behind the
camera like dagger don't move don't
he said you're standing there we just
right next door and it was he said it's
gonna be hard to get that kid and jackie
said we have to get that kid hard
that's jackie
that's what made the movies great at the
end oh yeah and then it's contagious
yeah yeah and i messed up one time he he
just acted a fool see you messed up you
messed up look at you you can't even
read chris you crazy
you keep in touch with michael you do
you talk to him regularly i see him
maybe a blue moon because he's all over
the world sometimes we bump into each
other when we're traveling like we
bumped into last time we was in london
and i knew michael was in the hotel
because everybody was outside yelling
and my god my god and i was mad because
my window they was yelling at my wonder
i said michael's on the other side of
the hotel
i gotta get some sleep i gotta interview
in the morning see my fear is that all
people in hong kong will think all
americans now i like chris tuck oh man
hong kong
i was the only black person in hong kong
i was looking for black people
i said where are the black people that
no black people no no they thought i was
kobe bryant man they didn't know
kobe bryant
like kobe kobe steinmeier grab kobe
we love you where's the [ __ ]
opening a comedy club here the next
month in las vegas congratulations
so maybe you can give me some advice
because i've never done anything like
this before how did that go for you
don't have your family working for you
okay in the comedy club because my
family worked for me and my kind of club
and i went there the club wasn't making
no money but everybody had new cars
that's what
my brother was drinking up all the
inventories i gotta try this stuff man
how long did it last about a year that
was it who made the call to shut it down
i did
this is over i'm not making no money
just gonna mess up my moving money were
they upset with you
my dad was upset with me because he was
the cook he was like what am i gonna do
now
be my daddy
you live in atlanta everyone
musically and and creatively they live
in atlanta yeah i'm from atlanta i'm
from the decatur georgia so i'm back and
forth from halfway in california i'm
halfway in georgia man so i love it down
there do they leave you alone in atlanta
uh sometimes man but people you know
they they sometimes because they don't
see a lot of celebrities so they be
coming up to me looking at me like hey
man
you you
you i'm like yeah me you you
like what you doing now in the grocery
store shopping i gotta eat too i'm
getting some food
you think i'm a superhero
so all of a sudden you know then we then
we got we got to know each other while
we was doing the movie man and now we
just like best of friends yeah well we
got in the fight one time oh really no
what you're getting it seems to me that
would be a hard fight to win well you
know it's
jackie ain't really a you know because
he see like you could beat attorneys
because they all you know you gotta bow
and all that so i don't bow back yeah
yeah i just slapped him right back in
here
but you you you do you right you go with
your family you have a church here that
you go to yeah i go to church man you
should come with me man you got to come
you don't want me to go to that come on
george you're on sunday man you can
blend in you look black already
that's what somebody told me about four
percent black
hey i'll tell you what i will go to
church i'll i'll let you take me to
church come on me how long is it going
to last because black church lasts
you know some
they do last too long mexican church in
about 45 minutes yeah are you serious
could you leave before the the
pre-sleeve you know you always say
black church is too long man preaching
every time i'll come back to night
service and it'd be tonight man
yesterday look outside you're the
kepler's here all day
only bad thing when you're a celebrity
and they know how much money you make
when they take up offering everybody
look at me they're like
they make 20 million movie you can pay
the church off
did one time i went dave chappelle
invited me to the com his comedy camp in
ohio springs field ohio dave's repel so
rich he bought a town his whole
i said oh man netflix love you
no but i'm serious i go in a sandwich
shop they're like come in they told me
you was coming come on in come on free
service free stuff you wanna have to go
down the street they've got a barber
shop down the street i said they they
own this town it's like
it's like the town prince was in in
purple rain yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah what are you having for lunch
he does all those same faces but it's
about lunch yes i don't know what you
have in your family i don't know i don't
know
whatever you have whatever you want
i don't know
whatever they serving i'll take whatever